the Venezuelan government's response to
recent US sanctions supporters of
Nicolas Maduro gathered in central
Caracas to denounce what they say is a
brutal embargo by the United States on
Monday US president Donald Trump signed
an executive order banning US companies
from doing business in Venezuela
he seized Venezuelan assets in the US
and threatened foreign powers and
companies doing business in this country
we met with opposition leader Huang
widow who has been challenging my
daughter's government
he says the sanctions are meant to
pressure Maduro into some sort of
negotiation the United States has
announced new sanctions I mean there's
already sanctions on video Issa there is
already sanctions on over 100
individuals from the government what do
you think this new sanctions will
achieve you know low capital in
Venezuela knows endow Venezuelan capital
has flooded the world economy it is
estimated and it's a wide guess because
of the magnitude of theft around 300 to
600 billion dollars was stolen from the
Venezuelan people to put it into context
that's 10 times or 15 times the Marshall
Plan in Europe after the second world
war they are part of the
money-laundering circuit these sanctions
are meant to put pressure on a
dictatorship and it's a tool of the free
world of modern diplomacy to pressure a
regime with the characteristics of
Maduro that have relationships with drug
trafficking proven in international
courts functions like this ones have
been implemented in Cuba in North Korea
in Iran and the leaders are still in
power and the population is poorer
suffering why do you think it's gonna be
different at this time but if I'm in the
whole know not lack of the problems we
face today are not the sanctions it's
the dictatorship the reason why
Venezuela is poor today is because the
expropriated fertile land and do not
grow anything in it
they destroyed national production they
stole productive land created fake
exchange controls and internal sanctions
that persecuted people that is what
keeps Venezuela poor the sanctions that
have human rights abusers thieves and
corrupt officials as an object
are meant to pressure a dictatorship I
don't want to compare the case with Cuba
Iran and North Korea or Syria I don't
know if the opposition had a role in
those countries how long they controlled
Parliament previous to the sanctions if
there were thousands of people on the
street each case is different and used
tools like diplomatic pressure sanctions
and protests in Venezuela isolating any
of these are a mistake you're talking
about talks about negotiations that are
happening in Barbados right now what
what can we expect from that melody go
it's a relative question what can we
expect from a dictatorship nothing what
can we expect of human rights abusers
nothing what we can do
our pressures we are implementing of
being the majority of institutional
pressure we could find a solution an
alternative to the conflict Venezuelans
are living in we are skeptical because
they have laughed at us in the past but
we have to cover all spaces and find a
solution that doesn't mean the
government wins time why though for now
discards the possibility of a military
intervention in spite that he says all
options are on the table but government
supporters say they're under attack now
and say they need to be ready for what
may come they say the sanctions will not
only hurt the government but will
increase the hardships they're already
facing every day terasawa
al Jazeera Caracas